hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game it's from round six
of the 2022 tata still tournament magnus
carlson versus rihardraport rapport
currently one of the leaders of the
tournament magnus trailing by half a
point it's quite an exciting game
features a lot of cool stuff and it
really shows how uh well basically how
every game is equal until it's not and i
i know that sounds like a stupid thing
to say but uh yeah i think you you will
agree that it fits this game very well
so uh let's check it out magnus uh
starts with the knight to f3 he goes for
the retty opening we have d5 by rapport
uh d4 by magnus knight to f6 and c4 and
now we have e6 basically transposing
into a queens again be declined g3 by
magnus we will see another catalan as
this is what magnus pretty much
exclusively plays now d captures on c4
and bishop to g2 we have knight to c6
and now castles and here
rook to b8 this is the main idea you
want to play b5 and you do not want your
rook stuck on a8 when the position opens
up and then there are some knights the
e5 ideas and anything can happen similar
to what we've seen in the world
championship match between magnus and
nipple
and here uh uh magnus could play a lot
of stuff for example knight to c3 is a
very well known move e3 is a very well
known move a4 is a very well known move
so most of those are kind of going after
that b5 idea but here magnus plays
bishop to e3 it's an incredibly rare
move it's been played some
well depending on what database you are
using either zero times or maybe seven
times uh but it is extremely rare and
one of the things that it says is that
the a7 pawn is still on a7 so you
haven't played a6 and it could be a
target potentially plus you're also just
defending your
d4 pawn uh once more and here the
there's basically a challenge for black
do you play knights to d5 right away and
say that this is a well this is a weird
move and while you could do this for
example knight e5 attacks the bishop
magnus would move the bishop attack the
queen bishop to e7 now let's say you
trade captures captures and now magnus
plays something like queen c1 goes after
the pawn so this is uh
kind of what what might occur b5 we're
going to challenge this structure with
b3 as the knight here is undefended so
it's very similar to what happened in
the game uh but that upward actually
after bishop to e3 spent i think some 20
minutes and played bishop to d6 and i
think this confused magnus somewhat
because it's not really amongst any of
the engine recommendations and it's a
really weird move to play uh so magnus
also took some 20 20 maybe something
minutes here to decide on the
on the approach and the the game exists
uh or rather the position exists in the
database knight with knight after d2 is
a known move uh but magnus just plays
queen to c1 as it it's very similar to
the position that we've already
discussed so magnus probably had that
one on the board at some point at home
uh and he or rather when i say on the
board i mean on his laptop or on the
computer and uh well he he wants to get
sort of a similar structure that he that
he knows so here we have b5 defending
the c4 pawn and magnus challenges it
with b3 again you cannot capture this
because the knight on c6 would be
hanging so bishop to b7 uh this is a
great uh diagonal for this bishop also
we're defending the knight so now we are
considering capturing on b3 but not
magnus just captures in c4 and he wins
back that pawn queen captures on c4 and
now knight to b4 uh so what do you play
here well magnus starts with a3 he
chases away this knight
just a second i think meadow wants to
come in
yeah that was middle
all right so a3 uh challenging the
knight and now knight is shifted over to
d5 so knight b to d5 and now uh we have
bishop to g5 we do not want to trade
this bishop for a knight so bishop to g5
and here robert finally castles we have
knight b to d2 magnus needs to continue
development and h6 asking what do you do
with this bishop and now magnus decides
to give up the bishop pair we have
bishop captures knight captures and now
rook f2c1 so both players have pretty
much developed all of their pieces and
the situation is rapport has the bishop
fair and it's a very nice bishop pair
and magnus has two pawn islands uh and
rapport has three pawn island so magnus
is a little bit better here so uh if
possible it's gonna be
maybe a little bit hard for rapper to
defend those isolated pawns uh but um
should be it should be okay i mean you
have the bishop pair and everything
should be fine but they are both burning
uh an incredible amount of time and it's
uh only moves 16. so here we have queen
uh uh sorry knights to d7 uh now with
ideas of maybe shifting the knight over
here then to d5 but also on b6 is just a
very nice piece and now queen to a4
moving with tempo as the a7 pawn is
still unprotected but now rapper just
plays c5
and what do you do here uh the idea is
if d captures on c5 we're going to play
knight captures in c5 attack the queen
and now magnus has to go back and black
just retains a better position because
if you capture this uh rook to a8 will
trap the queen there's no no where the
the black queen can go to as the knight
here also defends the bishop on b7 so
here after c5 queen captures on a7 right
away by magnus he accepts the challenge
and he says what do you got and both
players are down to 25 minutes already
and only move 18 so we still need to
play 22 more moves to reach time control
and here
it's a really really complicated
position uh for example i will give you
the absolute top uh
idea that
the engine
well is suggesting and that is bishop to
d5
such a funky move to play uh but once
you see it you you believe it because
the point is uh before before this movie
is played you want to play the rook to
a8 and trap the queen but we can't do
that because the bishop here is hanging
and we still haven't had the trait here
so the knight defends the bishop so
that's why you move the bishop and now
you are threatening this very nasty rook
to a8 move and after the queen moves to
a6 now we play attack the bishop bishop
will move to e7 now we're going to play
e3 and now we're just gonna have a trade
rook to a8 and after the queen moves for
example queen to d3 uh now look at this
the a3 pawn will also become attacked so
c captures on d4 knight captures on d4
and now a lot a lot of moves are
possible the bishops here can be traded
off first also you can capture on a3
so black will not have any problems um
uh defending this but after queen
captures on a7 rapport does not go for
this and uh since both of them are
playing this uh incredibly incredibly
complicated uh engine preparation yeah
you have to spot even when you're out of
theory or out of the book you have to
continue playing like an engine
otherwise your position just becomes bad
so here that ruppert played bishop
captures on f3 and now magnus needs to
decide what to capture with of course
we're not considering pawn captures but
uh knight captures and bishop captures
is definitely an option uh the idea if
knight captures then again rook to a8
and everything gets traded off let's say
queen b7 we're gonna capture here knight
captures we can play rook captures on a3
equal material nothing to worry about
pretty much for for black so
he would enjoy this so magnus decides to
go for bishop captures on f3 it's a
little bit more complicated but the
bishop is not blocked by the knight so
rook to a8 will not be an option in any
of the lines uh and upward place c
captures on the e4 and now magnus just
goes rook to a2 you could also just
start by pushing the a4 pawn but magnus
plays rook to a2 first uh it prevents
rook to beat you could be uh annoying in
some lines also you can double up on the
c file you can double up on the a file
easily so it's a very
flexible idea and here again you have to
play very very precisely and the idea
you want to play
is knight to e5 now there are some
tricky d3 moves but knight to the e5 is
basically what you want to go for
and now after white starts pushing
you're going to capture here after
knight characters play e5 and now your
your pawns are marching forward this
will be very good for black however
after rook to a2 ruppert played queen to
e7 and although it doesn't seem like uh
all that much has changed this is uh a
very big change in the position and
magnus now just starts pushing the past
a pawn and how are you how are you
stopping this the bishop here controls
the a8 square and on top of that we have
bishops of opposite color so while
defending this position it's as we
usually say black is basically down a
piece because the black the dark square
bishop will not be able to oppose the
light square bishop and now if you try
something like e5 we're just going to
play a5 and now if for example f5 trying
to do something there's this bishop to
c6 idea
attacking the knight here so we'll be
able to save our bishop from from being
challenged with tempo as the knight now
hangs so rapport starts with rook after
d8 sort of uh anticipating this line but
now magnus just plays queen captures on
d4
so rapper gives up the d for pawn uh
he he thought that the idea that we've
just shown isn't worth playing even with
the material equality so he decides to
give up the pawn rather
but now rook to b4 attacking the queen
queen to c3 and the knight to b6 it
seems like you have a compensation for
the pawn as your pieces are very active
but again a5 with tempo chases away the
knight we have queen the a7 now you
can't capture because the rook is
hanging but now magnus just pins the
knight uh queen to e3 now the knight
cannot move uh or rather you could move
the knight you could play something like
knight here but uh then the problem is
rook captures on c8 we just remove the
defender of the of the queen and if
queen captures an e3 we of course first
capture the rook with check after king
moves we pick up the queen and we are up
too much material so after queen e3
bishop to e7 is played
and now magnus just plays rook c to c2
uh doubling up here on the second rank
and now the rook is guarding the rook on
a2 so you can just play a captures on b6
and there really isn't all that much for
rapper to try here bishop to g5 was
played with queen to c5 bishop back to
a7 attacking the queen but now the
simplest solution is the correct one a
captures on b6 is just winning for
magnus this is what he played pointing
if the queen is captured we're going to
play b captures on a7 and white is
completely winning now and uh if queen
captures an a2 which was played in the
game now magnus just picks up on e7 now
threatening the rook here also the queen
is hanging so rapper captures on c2 but
now we play queen captures on the 8 with
check king to h7 and now b7 the pawn is
nicely protected by the bishop our queen
covers the knight and it was in this
position on move 31 that uh richard
rapport resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so really a
brutal display of how how complicated uh
chess is uh played
rap played everything perfectly
basically and he had uh he he's having
an amazing tournament so far uh but the
one one slight misstep in in such a
critical position where i mean according
to the engine it's not much it's like
1.4 1.5
but um
when you're a human playing against
magnus and magnus is upon it and it's a
past
outside past a pawn that's not something
you stop easily you have to play perfect
chess and that's not easy so this was a
a well-deserved win for magnus and he uh
well if you look at the score magnus is
not doing all that great okay he caught
up to the leaders but uh out of all the
games that he played
he should have won like three more if he
if he would was able to
uh well seize the advantage that he got
but his opponents defended well and he
didn't find the best continuations and
this is something that will be
necessary if magnus is to reach his new
goal new set goal of reaching 2900
rating in classical chess and you resign
here as i know you guys like me to
finish the games for example we're
threatening just queening the pawn so
you have to play something to stop this
but now we can just play queen d7 we
attack this pawn and there's really
nothing
black can do everything is nicely
defended if you try king g6 that defend
the f7 pawn we can even sacrifice the
bishop here now you have to capture
otherwise we just pick up here so
captures captures with check and now
it's a king hunter that will not end
well for black knight f3 king to g4
queen g6 check king to h3 and now we
finish it with a nice checkmate queen h5
check only move rogue blocks and now
queen captures on h4 will be checkmate
so this is what would happen if they
actually continued the game but of
course the rapport knows that there is
no point in continuing this
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed a very nice victory uh by magnus
and we'll see what happens in the other
games we're definitely showing um at
least one more uh game from this round
and then we're going to discuss the
standings uh i would like to thank
matthew waldez uh mohan churalandi
maliki heaven ron swanson and tom earl
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular tournament until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day